66 aviones y 14 buques de guerra se
desplegaron solo el domingo según
funcionarios taiwaneses el epílogo de
cuatro días durante los cuales china
habría multiplicado las maniobras
militares en ocasiones a menos de 20
kilómetros de los bordes taiwaneses y
disparando misiles balísticos sobre la
isla para los expertos chinos que acuden
más a los platós de televisión la
demostración de fuerza fue un éxito
demostró la determinación pero también
la capacidad el ejército popular de
liberación para proteger los intereses
del país y preservar su soberanía e
integridad territorial
solíamos decir que el ejército debía
intervenir como último recurso en
cualquier desafío o provocación así que
estas maniobras militares son muy
importantes para china y para el resto
del mundo
estas maniobras culminaron con un
bloqueo simulado de taiwán por parte del
ejército chino el sábado una respuesta
con músculo a la visita de nancy pelosi
a la isla hace unos días una medida
considerada como una grave provocación
por parte de china que reclama la
soberanía sobre esta isla democrática y
sus 23 millones de habitantes la
reacción fue totalmente desproporcionada
según washington cuando taipei acusó a
beijing de amenazar la paz en la región
las maniobras han terminado pero china
tiene previsto realizar nuevos
ejercicios en los próximos días esta vez
en el mar amarillo que separa a china de
la península de corea